bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france alors avant
de rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
voulais tout simplement
que vous rebondissez sûr qu'on vient
d'entendre
emmanuel macron estime ce soit en
parlant de la crise des gilet jaune que
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas
qu'est ce que cette phrase vous inspire
l'ancien régime la parole d'un monarque
qui la met un coup d'épée au pacte
républicain à la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité il parle de dignité égale il
ne parle pas de droits égaux finalement
un citoyen il a le droit de vote il
c'est une parole égal c'est la parole
également d'un député d'un élu de la
nation comme il le dit mais là on voit
très bien comment est mené le maquereau
on essaye de faire passer finalement ce
message qu'il est le chef en son palais
alors avec ses poulains vous avez
également regarder un cette intervention
du chef de l'état en gros que retenir de
ces deux heures d'interviews
rien
l'auto satisfaction narcissique du
président des riches comme lui-même
n'aime pas être appelé il a fait un
bilan difficile à tenir en réalité un
bilan compliqué parce que il n'a pas pu
faire les réformes qu'il voulait faire
parce que il ya beaucoup d'échecs dans
ce bilan et parce que finalement il ne
n'accepte pas l'autocritique ni la
critique donc on a eu à faire simplement
à une mise en scène de cette de ce
pouvoir présidentiel
qui est en incapacité aujourd'hui on le
voit à la fois crise sanitaire mais
aussi sur la réponse l'angoissent face
au pouvoir d'achat
l'idée c'est qu emmanuel macron est le
meilleur président que la france ait
jamais connu on en est loin évidemment
mais il y a là un personnage extrêmement
narcissique avec une vision presque
autoritaire du pouvoir mais au moins
verticale du pouvoir qui entend bien
décider seul d'ailleurs pas une fois au
cours de cet entretien n'ont été nommés
les ministres ou même le premier
ministre il est seul il est seul à
gouverner et il se met seul en scène
dans ce palais de l'elysée alors on
disait tout à l'heure
certains membres de l'opposition à
grincent déjà des dents quand à cette
intervention du président de la
république et estime que conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel doit
décompter le temps de parole des manuels
maquereau en vue de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
est ce que le csa doit intervenir à ceux
à ce niveau là
oui clairement le sait ça l'a déjà fait
par le passé il ya des règles qui
existent sur le temps de parole que ce
soit celui du président qui même s'il
n'est pas encore déclaré candidat parce
qu'on rentre dans les mois qui vont être
les mois de la campagne présidentielle
donc il n'y a pas de raison que cette
parole là soit enlevée du temps de
parole politique d'ailleurs il passe son
temps à jouer avec ses règles lors de
l'entretien il disait à darius rochebin
qu'il ne faisait pas de politique il ne
fait que cela évidemment allant même
jusqu'à lire une lettre avec les prénoms
des enfants qui avait écrit une lettre à
joséphine baker pour répondre à eric
zemmour sur l'idée des prénoms donc on
est vraiment là dans quelque chose de
l'ordre du jeu avec les règles le csa
doit bien sûr tranché et assez
rapidement parce que emmanuel macron va
tout faire pour se déclarer candidat le
plus tard possible il a encore joué avec
les questions d'ailleurs à cette
occasion en disant qu'ils ne
répondraient pas vraiment ce soir il ne
donnerait pas l'exclusivité à la chaîne
tf1 de sa candidature alors vous le
disais à l'instant emmanuel macron n'a
toujours pas annoncé
sa candidature ou pas à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
vous le disiez il va peut-être l'annoncé
le plus tard possible qu'est ce que
emmanuel macron a gagné justement le
fait d'annoncer sa candidature assez
tard
tout simplement de pouvoir faire
campagne sans faire campagne donc de ne
pas avoir de frais c'est l'impôt des
citoyens qui lui finance cette campagne
de réélection aussi le fait d'aller
laisser les ministres préparer l'opinion
publique
les éléments de langage tester des
choses et puis entrer le plus tard
possible parce qu'il n'a pas intérêt à
rentrer avant la prise de la présidence
du conseil européen et que le il est
déjà omniprésent pas une semaine sans
deux heures minimum d'emmanuel macron
sur tous les médias confondus pour dire
qu'il est le meilleur et qu'il doit
continuer 50 plus et pourtant même s'il
se défend d'être candidat son parti la
république en marche a déjà imprimé les
tracts 50 plus est déjà en train de
faire les marchés les ministres
également sont partout en campagne donc
c'est vraiment un jeu totalement
hypocrite qui mériterait d'être dénoncés
c'est ce que font d'ailleurs les autres
candidats en disant que c'est totalement
un jeu qui est trompeur et où les règles
ne sont pas les mêmes pour tous et c'est
injuste si on veut parler de démocratie
alors il faut remettre un jeu
démocratique qui est le même pour tous
là clairement il ne m'a comparé avec une
longueur d'avancé en jouant avec les
règles alors le but de cette
intervention était de faire un bilan de
du quinquennat dix jours avant avant
noël est ce que le timing est bon est ce
que les français avaient envie et
d'entendre le bilan du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron non on verra les
chiffres d'audience demain
de toute façon je crois qu'il une
fatigue des français il en parlait
d'ailleurs de cette fatigue des français
c'est pas seulement le coc vite je pense
que c'est la fatigue de ses cinq ans
deux quinquennats d' emmanuel macron où
il y à une maltraitance il parlait des
manifestants et puis on a bien vu que
les manifestants n'avaient pas une
parole égal il n'avait même pas des
droits égaux puisqu'ils ont été traités
avec une violence inédite un sous la
vème et là on a exactement cette idée de
cette mise en scène perpétuel où il
continue à faire ce qu'il sait donc il
s'en fiche de ce que les français
attendent en réalité ils suisse son
agenda personnel et ils avaient décidé
d'ailleurs d'enregistrer cette émission
de ne pas la faire en direct donc on ne
parle pas de sujets comme la mise en
garde à vue d'alexandre benalla dans le
cadre d'une enquête ou d'autres sujets
qui pourraient fâcher il balaie d'un
revers de main également les accusations
sur nicolas hulot enfin il ya quelque
chose là dedans c'est pathétique
finalement qui montre aussi une certaine
fébrilité du pouvoir parce que il y à
des candidats qui commence à monter dans
les sondages et lui se dit que peut-être
il pourrait ne pas passer ne pas faire
la même entourloupe en 2017 face à
marine le pen et là ce serait beaucoup
plus difficile pour lui donc on sent
cette fébrilité avec cette volonté
d'être tout le temps présent dans le jeu
médiatique merci beaucoup alexis blanc
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
pour arte france merci beaucoup